rescue operations continue across
Southern turkey and parts of Northern
Syria after two powerful earthquakes hit
the region early on Monday at least 4
800 people have been killed across the
two countries the World Health
Organization is warning the death toll
could rise eight-fold
the region of hate in southern turkey is
one of the worst affected more than 1
200 buildings have been destroyed in the
province people spent Monday nights
sifting through Rubble looking for any
signs of life
we heard him they're calling out asking
for help they asked to be rescued we
cannot rescue them how can we rescue
them nobody has come since this morning
nobody we have nobody look around look
it's certainly we have the voices our
children are in there what can we do the
building is already partially collapsed
this is human life what can you do when
you hear calls for help there are no
emergency workers no soldiers nobody
this is a neglected place
well let's speak to Karim cynic he's the
head of the Turkish red crescent he
joins us by phone from karaman maras
you're at the epicenter of the Quake can
you give us a sense of of what it is
like there now and the conditions that
you are facing
uh two major earthquakes of magnitude
7.7 and 7.6 uh
hit the sawdust in Turkey on Monday in
same day and we have more than 3 300
people died and more than Club 20 000
people were injured actually over uh
5500 building uh totally collapsed and
thousands of others uh also heavily
dimagged uh and almost 20 000 surgeon
rescue and humanitarian response uh
staff at the field but the huge area
wide area and we have very heavy winter
conditions uh our roads have been
affected from earthquake and having
winter conditions snow and other
conditions so we are trying to reach out
every affected Regional sub-region
Turkish red creation society as
a local Nation Society
we are working with our 2000 stuff and
200 vehicles and our tents and blankets
and others basic humanitarian assistance
items we are here to respond as soon as
possible and as much as possible and we
deployed our mobile kitchens to the
affected provinces we have 10 provinces
and three of them heavily affected
authorities have declared This Disaster
as a level for Allah that calls for
international assistance and uh turkey
uh
mobilized all our domestic capacity
shelters search and rescue food Health
Care capacity to the affected region but
we need some other assistance abroad
can you talk a little bit about the
damage to the infrastructure like the
the roads and the airports in the region
and how difficult that is making it for
you and your teams to get to some of
these areas have you been able to get to
all of the the regions affected at this
point
[Music]
airport
as yesterday close to take off and
Landing but authorities trying to
teach
the damage and the highways as well but
in the meantime water switch system
natural gas piping systems electricity
and telecommunication lines also have
been effective so it's really difficult
to communicate and to thrusters
our items to the affected areas but
by the the second base today so Alpha
disaster Authority and our team
will be reached out to every affected
areas by our uh essentially the
meditation items you mentioned the
weather and obviously we know that
that's making
um an already really dire situation even
even more grim
can you give us an understanding of of
just how the freezing temperatures and
and the rain and the snow is affecting
uh the the search and rescue efforts and
and I guess the survival rate for those
that are still stuck in the rubble
uh yes uh actually our local uh capacity
the staff and our volunteers have been
affected because of the earthquake so uh
we obliged to deploy our additional
response team for our neighboring
provinces and the weather conditions uh
show uh bad and heavy and it's really
difficult to reach the affected areas by
roads and by air and our search and
rescue uh teams from different ngos and
gender Mario and uh offat the disaster
authorities are working
under this heavily uh heavy weather
conditions snow wet wind and minus
degree uh also weather conditions and
it's really difficult to work here but
uh we have huge solidarity among nations
and we have huge solidarity among the
humanitarian sectors in the world at I
believe that uh we will we will overcome
this big disaster and catastrophe okay
thank you so much for your time I know
you're obviously going to be extremely
busy for the days and and weeks and
months ahead um there is the head of the
Turkish red crescent uh he uh joined us
by Throne from uh karaman maras which is
near the epicenter of one of the large
earthquakes I just want to stay on these
pictures for the next uh little moment
or two these are the some of the search
and rescue teams that we were just
talking about and what you see here is
that they stop every few minutes to
listen to see if they can hear any
survivors that are still trapped under
the rubble
they will come to a complete standstill
and wait to see if they can hear
anything from underneath the tons and
tons of rubble that have fallen and then
frantically start digging again if and
when they do hear any noise from those
survivors but we're going to go to uh
synonym cosiolu who is in Istanbul where
she is monitoring developments and so uh
obviously a huge search and rescue
operation under underway across such a
wide region can you just give us an idea
of the international Aid and assistance
that has that has been offered by uh by
by some of the countries
oh well all neighboring countries and
friendly countries of turkey as turkey
is also a NATO Ally have offered their
help to Turkey since the beginning of
this earthquake more than 60 Nations
offered this help we heard the United
States other Western countries Russia
Azerbaijan Georgia Greece trying to help
turkey by offering to send rescue
workers a humanitarian and medical
supplies for this deadly earthquake to
help the civilians trapped in these
areas of course these are being
coordinated by the Turkish authorities
in Ankara as everything needs to be
planned even
reaching out to people giving delivering
the AIDS everything needs to be
coordinated as the area hit by the
earthquake yesterday morning is also
prone to some technical problems like a
four airports have been shut down since
yesterday the highways are some of them
are destroyed so it is not easy to
access these areas and we're hearing
that there are some areas not only in
the rurals but also some centers I
haven't been able to be accessed by the
rescue workers because of these
technical reasons so this is very
important and as Karam Clinic said a
Turkish red crescent director said yes
turkey is working in full capacity but
it is not enough so that's why the
Turkish authorities announced a level 4
alarm code yesterday which means turkey
requires International assistance and it
is also coming one by one and some of
them are already on the ground working
with the Turkish volunteers and Turkish
rescue workers but we more than 24 hours
is behind and as the time each hour is
critical from now on until the 17th
72nd hour following the earthquake this
is why more help is needed more carriers
are needed to reach out to these areas
sometimes when you look at the social
media and when you look at the news
people accuse the government of being
late in response but time will show us
how everything is well organized or not
well organized but everybody is blaming
the urbanization in the area okay just
looking at these these pictures uh the
search and rescue workers are still
trying their hardest to find survivors
in the rubble there's obviously
aftershocks so there's been hundreds of
aftershocks can you tell us about how
that is affecting other people on the
ground in these regions
actually
for aftershocks these have very strong
magnitude since yesterday as you said
hundreds of aftershocks happened from
5.0 to 6.6 magnitude which is like a a a
separate earthquake and yesterday turkey
has suffered two earthquakes around the
same magnitude so for rescue workers
getting under those Rebels or getting
over those level down buildings is also
critical because as they are trying to
move during aftershocks those damaged
buildings have the risk to fall down and
fall apart that's why even the lives of
the rescue workers are under a threat
right now and we are hearing that people
people the rescue workers are hearing
the voices of the trapped people down
below the level uh the the collapsed
buildings but these are works that needs
full concentration and silence and of
course help from outside that's why the
authorities have made calls for the
civilians if they have nothing to do in
the city they should leave the city so
that the rescue workers response groups
would be able to work more comfortably
another thing that challenges the rescue
workers is the climate condition it is
winter time and Eastern Turkey always
suffers harsh winters at this time it is
snowing if there is heavy snow in
Malaysia and aduyaman and in some cities
this heavy weather condition is expected
to continue throughout the week and
there is rain that's why it is also
difficult for the rescue workers to get
under those rubbles
and it is it doesn't finish it doesn't
finish when you pull out the people from
under the rebels you have to provide
them shelters this is all a big
coordination a big organization that all
both authorities and rescue workers
response scripts need to work together
with okay thank you so much that is
synonym kosiolu for us out of Istanbul
with the latest developments
well across the border in neighboring
Syria the government is calling for
urgent help from the United Nations at
least 1 600 people were killed in the
earthquakes there hundreds of families
in the north are trapped under destroyed
buildings or the disaster has added to
Missouri already faced by millions of
syrians displaced by 11 years of Civil
War many are living in makeshift camps
well I know kiman is the regional
director for the Middle East with Mercy
Court he joins us from Beirut thank you
very much for being on Al Jazeera I
guess first of all we've heard a lot
about the situation in Turkey can you
just bring us up to date with uh the
search and rescue efforts in in Northern
Syria
well the situation in Northern CA is
pretty similar to the one in turkey
last yesterday was very difficult uh for
everybody the communications were very
spotty so we had a hard time reaching
our staff most of them had their house
damaged and and of course this is
happening to a population that is
largely displaced and has been as you
said uh and a very difficult situations
for the past 10 years have you even been
able to get into some of the worst
affected areas to or get information out
of the worst affected areas to to to I
guess gather as much information as you
can to know where people and rescue
teams need to go
yeah so we immediately started to
reassess the areas where we are already
operating which is like 98 uh camps but
we also very aware that uh the camps are
not initially the most uh affected
because the people who are living in
houses
were extremely uh uh touched by these
earthquake so we are now assessing
another 136 communities in the same
areas of people who unfortunately had to
spend the last night out uh outside with
the weather is absolutely uh horrible
with the the rain and the snow
and obviously uh 10 11 years of civil
war is just making the situation even
more Grim can you give us a sense of
what it's like for those people um that
are on the ground obviously with very
little Aid or help at this point in time
and and the conditions that they are
facing
yeah so we are talking about a
population that has been uh struggling
to get access to all the basic services
our activity was mostly to provide with
the water through a water Trucking
um there was also very difficulty to
access food the price of food has almost
doubled over the past years because of
the institution in Ukraine
um so a very awarding situation and most
recently at the end of last year we had
a an outbreak of Cholera which now is
one of our main worries because we've
learned that uh boreholes have been
affected by the earthquake which added
some mud in the water and and might make
it very hard to to access clean water so
we are very worried about uh possible
return of Cholera uh how do you go about
getting International Aid and assistance
into Syria into into these affected
regions and how much more difficult is
that because of the the situation in the
country
yeah so this is a defining aspect of the
situation in Northwest area uh all the
supply lines are going through turkey
and given the situation just across the
border these Sublime lanes are extremely
weak uh today and and they were
yesterday so we are trying to find
suppliers who manage to find ways to get
a
food and and Equipment across the border
the main one for you may 108 was closed
by valhawa and we're hoping that this
will reopen very soon but definitely
that's a very major challenge of that
response okay thank you so much uh for
your time uh we really appreciate uh
that's Anno came in from Mercy Corps
with us from Beirut